for as long as I can remember I've been
installing Microsoft Office on my
computers but even though I shell out a
couple hundred bucks every few years to
upgrade I find myself spending less time
here and more time here in Google Docs
or here Apple's I work of course many of
the 1.1 billion people who use Microsoft
Office end up living in Word Excel or
PowerPoint but you can find those
features and other programs ones with
better collaboration tools and web
functionality and they'll let you open
and edit your office documents so the
question is do you still need Microsoft
Office yes we're going to need this
spreadsheet to explain Microsoft 365
pricing since you don't buy the software
outright anymore instead now you pay $7
per month to install it on one computer
and $10 to put it on five to make you
feel better about paying for software
Microsoft now includes
a whopping terabyte of cloud storage for
every user but still there's something
about this place that just feels like
home sure this ribbon got in the way but
I still know exactly where to find
things and if I dream up a feature it's
probably in here someplace
whoa confidential button believe it or
not Microsoft also offers free web
versions of them the downside is that
they're more limited but Microsoft's
biggest shortcoming is in real-time
collaboration where several people can
work on your document at the same time
but that's where Google zaps shine
Google has free Web Apps for word
processing spreadsheets and
presentations but everything happens
online all the basics are there though
it certainly doesn't have the formatting
and template richness of Microsoft's
gold standard
besides Google's interfaces are starting
to look pretty tired but editing that
document on any device and working on
that document with someone remotely is
too easy
there's my editor again tearing through
this week's column is he on his iPhone
his computer his tablet doesn't matter
apples I work is the third major office
suite though it's mainly available on
Apple devices Pages Keynote and numbers
come free with all Macs and with tablet
versions for the iPad there are also
free versions on the web that anyone can
use I works features make your documents
shine and its web and desktop apps are
the best design of all of them
Apple's real time collaboration is also
now quite good though I wish I could add
comments all right so do you really need
Microsoft Office well it still offers
the most features but the big question
is do you even use all those tools
Google Apple and even Microsoft offer
the basics for free but paying for the
full version of Office still makes sense
if you want those extras and a really
good deal on cloud storage for now I'm
going to keep bouncing between them all
but I can't say for how much longer I'm
going to keep buying and installing
office